why do Iranian hate Britain well partly
because they've got pretty good reason
to historically and partly because it
suits their government it goes back to
the age of empire not just Britons but
the Persian one that once stretched from
Greece to India rightly or wrongly and
it's a bit of both we get much of the
blame for its shrinking
helping to carve out a chunk of it to
Russia in 1813 which earned us the
nickname wily old Fox that are chunked
to the East in Afghanistan half a
century later and it wasn't just land by
1913 the British government had
extracted a contract effectively making
all Iranian oil British property a few
years later another giving it control of
Iran's army and Treasury in 1953 Britain
and America helped stage a coup to
overthrow the elected government of
Mohammad Mossadegh who had begun taking
back control of Iran's oil iran's
experiment with democracy was snuffed
out and the charr installed instead
Britain has been reviled ever since as
the little Satan
second only to America's Great Satan and
we've been blamed for whatever America
does to not least during the eight year
long iran-iraq war when the West
supported Iran's enemy Saddam Hussein
and more than a million Iranians died
it is also though convenient fir'aun's
government to have someone else to blame
for the country's problems especially
its economy and the government
encourages anti British and
anti-american feeling with massive
state-sponsored graffiti and regular
demonstrations denouncing the West when
he go to Iran he find this strange
ambivalence on the one hand there are
demonstrations on the streets of Tehran
where they chant death to Britain on the
other you meet some of the friendliest
most welcoming people on earth who are
insatiably curious about the outside
world including Britain after the
nuclear deal Britain and other European
countries are pursuing a kind of date on
Twitter on even if under Trump America
isn't the hope for Britain and Iran is
both countries can move on to something
that's frankly a bit more grown-up for
Iranians that would include stopping
arresting British Iranian guests of
their country on obscure charges without
presenting convincing evidence for
Britain it's helping the Iranians
genuinely benefit from the nuclear deal
and for both it's about being as honest
as possible with the other there's one
Iranian street vendor said to me while I
was there we don't hate British people
just the politics so let's move beyond
the politics
what we have in common as people